like I really want people to [__] win
I really want it nobody's taken for me
everyone's winnings don't come from me
I'm gonna get mine you know if you're
great you should only be cheering for
people there's no time for Envy there's
no time for jealousy there's no time for
gossiping at dinner tearing down
somebody that's winning I'm shooting for
[__] in my own industry other Ad
Agency if they're good enough they're
good enough like I'm cheering for people
because nobody's taking a penny or a
smile out of my pocket and so that's who
the guy is yeah I mean for me like I I
admire so much of what Sean does and
this you know that you know complex con
and what I did with K-Swiss when I
started getting a little more you know
collaborative and then with Reebok is
I've got something brewing with be
friends and Reebok coming out later this
year and we did a preview to that with
Sean and like I mean you know this Nick
because you guys are partners and real
friends like there's not a single person
on here that if they have the luxury of
meeting this man in real life doesn't go
from admiration for his creative
superpowers to Deep
deep appreciation for the humanity and
kindness and love that comes out of this
man soul and like you know actually 2023
for me is like a real Focus
to I'm like thinking a lot more about
efficiency in my travel and and just in
general all to open up more time for
more more friendships you know between
family and work that's just kind of how
I roll but I want to really open up more
room for friendships as as Sean knows as
you know Nick between DM or texting I'm
pretty good like that right I check in I
want to support but my actual hours so
many people like for example even on
this on this spaces right now so many
people don't realize that I'm running a
2 000 person company and that Victor X
is doing hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars in
Revenue that by itself is a 15-hour job
then there's V friends then there's the
garyvee thing then there's the investor
thing then there's like actually still
caring about wine techs and Wine Library
for my dad so but I'm so focused on
opening up room to expand on my
friendships I'm going out to you know
right after a year I'm going out to
another dinner with the couple that I
would have lo I 40 times I tried to have
dinner with in the last two years zero
dinners now I'm doing it tonight so Sean
is one of those people that I have great
love for you're the same Nick where it's
like real for business friendship real
you know there's a I call them
acquaintance pluses people I got real
love for that I can recognize
immediately I know a lot about them I
give them love then there's friends you
know that I don't get to spend time with
so this is pretty fun to do this on the
18th with the two of you because you
guys fit in a category of my New Year's
resolution though I don't I'm saying
that for fun it's it's a life resolution
which is I need to find more capacity
for more hours for friends and
um I'm happy to be here with you guys
tonight and and I hope that little rant
maybe inspired someone to text someone
they've been wanting to get drinks with
actually and maybe pull it off next week
I I saw that there was a couple comments
or some notes in the discords or like
how do you guys how do you get these how
do you get these gets and you know I
didn't respond but you know what I I
would say to this audience is like you
know it's 20 years of work right and
it's like you and I have crossed paths
so many times over the years and it was
a hello it was a nod it was a
collaboration it was a something was
Snoop like we just we we've gotten in
the mix and got to know each other and
become genuine friends and when the time
comes and you and you lean into people
and you ask them hey can you can you
appear can you make this it's really
purely a friendship so that's why I
think what you just said really
resonated me I was going to say that
anyway so so thank you for joining us
I'm so glad you said that because I was
petrified we talked the other night
and you know I thought you said we're
gonna say that the people in the
community were going to say why doesn't
garyvee have any mintage nfts yet and as
you started talking my my heart dropped
because like [__] you know because I did
something about it I did something about
a year ago which is like created a
totally separate laptop and hard wallet
for purchasing and there's so much
friction in that because it's like you
know like locked up and this and that
and so it's not in my face the way it
was a year ago when it was in my laptop
and on a hot wallet and things that
nature so thank God you were saying
something sweet but I still have to be I
have to be loud and accountable don't
worry crew like it's very hard you know
I always say bet on the jockeys like
most of what I invested in you know
world of women or women and weapons or
you know like like uh definitely
definitely Moon Birds there's only two
categories for me I either subjectively
love the art back to women and weapons
or I completely believe in the Opera
operator like Moon birds and so for me
you two being teamed up on this I have
you know and I've been transparent with
you the three times we've talked about
this like I'm in this crazy cocoon right
now I'm gonna get out of it because we
launched the friends.com yesterday the
new website we've got two big Tech
launches here but like I I really like
I'm actually actually gonna try to hang
up here Dustin's here filming in case we
get content out of this I'm gonna try to
get it to force me to like do what I
have to do here so uh mintage Community
don't worry I'm coming on board and it's
and it's like I have no you know I'm
done with the whole like nobody buy it
because I'm buying it that's speculation
and you know Gold Rush days are over I'm
doing it because of what I've always
done which is like I find it hard to not
believe in the two of you and I'm aware
that you guys have lots going on and you
may you know get sidetracked and do
other things but like hey I want to
support you because that's important to
me because you guys are friends and B
you know you guys are two real people
like you do think business actually this
is not hyperbole you don't play one on
Instagram and so that gives me
confidence it's it's ultimately why I
think V friends will be the most
successful project I'm aware consciously
that they're absolutely and you look at
the incredible work of board eight and
others uh Luca what he's doing project
penguins like there's people doing it
like I may not build the best project in
the next 25 years
but I'm gonna be in the [__] mix
because that's the story of my 25-year
career
he's like hey Gary go get a men's Fest
the goal here is like we just want a
Vibe and talk
into the world that we're building
something that's slow and steady we you
know we we set out just build a small
community and by small a thousand is
actually quite big but we didn't set out
to build something too big we wanted to
build something that we could really
really kind of connect with and prove
that Sean and I are what we're thinking
about how it applies
vegetables so you know for us like again
it's just about showing Improvement well
you know it's it's so cool everyone
talks about like gifts and curses and
timing you two are so fortunate you're
not fortunate that you didn't launch it
15 months ago when you know it would
have went for a trillion dollars and all
that you are fortunate that there's a
lot of baggage that came along with that
gold rush I feel it daily like you know
the people that bought day one cool but
like after you know depending on what
timing was you know it's underwater and
like for me it's a 50-year project and
so like you feel the pressure even from
people that are gracious forget about
the people that are loud about it for
you like there's a big part of me that
that thinks this is an incredible time
for real people to launch a project
there's so much upside everything is so
priced in a com on its Merit not the
hysteria and the flip and I think for
real operators look there's never a bad
time to launch a good business and
there's never a good time to launch a
bad business right so so like yes I'm
aware when I launch be friends and I'm
aware with like the trials and
tribulations of the chaos the last 15
months but like you're 13 it's going to
be what it's going to be say now if you
suck and you launch in this com Market
good news it's still gonna suck but on
the flip side if you're good
to be able to launch right now is a
[__] blessing because it doesn't come
with any of the hyperbole of a gold rush
and you can just kind of build
I mean I think we're thinking about the
application of the software we're
thinking about the NFC we're thinking
about the asset the the collectible but
we're just really thinking about how
does it amplify Our Lives how does
someone like Sean who's an icon and a
vintage connoisseur and a creative think
about it in terms of you know wearables
um how can I apply it to music and
artists so these are the types of
questions that we have time and it's a
little quieter we can confront and we
can you know work with some of these
best these amazing development teams
like non-fungible labs and things like
that hey hey Sean by the way real quick
Sean are you around May 18th to the 20th
I spent the entire day today on vcon
speaking casting and it's we're going
crazy this year okay great so uh Dustin
can you make that
um brother it's really gonna be cool
obviously last year Nick and Snoop and
champ along with Pharrell and even
others brought a lot of the flavor but
this year I'm going more culture
business like I'm bringing I'm trying to
bring as many CMOS and CEOs so people
can learn business and marketing at the
highest levels and I want cool and I
find you at the tippy top of cool
fashion like the like the people that
the people that confirmed today were
bananas and I'm excited to have you
there
hell yeah no thanks I appreciate that
I'm really I'm really stoked with that
that'll be dope for sure cool and uh
kind of like you said my it's funny
hearing you talk about making time for
friends this year because
I've always been so envious of my
friends who are great friends uh I just
have to call out one person my homie
itai he's probably one of the best just
friends in general to anyone that I've
ever met and I would always find myself
referencing him and I'm like wow it's
incredible how he makes time for
everyone in his life like I've never met
someone like that who just like always
has time for you you know what's cool
really I'm sorry
man this year I'm sorry to interrupt or
jump in here like that's so insane to me
because
one of my best friends that I think is
like a great great great great great
great great friend is Aton yours is etai
Right Aton Sugarman big roses to you
brother for the P A lot of people know
who you are in the New York scene over
the last 25 years talk about like the
definition of a friend
yeah I love that
no it's it's cool I mean that's so it
was cool hearing you focus on that this
year because that's like my big Focus so
it's like you know time for friends but
luckily all my friends do cool stuff so
I think it'll be a fun year yeah it's
awesome
who don't know you at this point you
know because I think a lot are are
really tech savvy Tech forward and see
whatever but for the for that 0.001 I
just wanna because because to me you're
prolific but who is garyvee
uh you know I'm I'm a really very simple
dude believe it or not for all the chaos
and all that stuff like I'm an
entrepreneur who's an immigrant first
generation born in the Soviet Union
right who like came over and like did
his family proud right like walked into
the family Merchant liquor store
business and changed the course of the
entire family's life and then at 34. one
of the reasons I push patience on every
kid on social media is you know I spent
the first 12 years of my career seven
days a week in a liquor store not nine
to five you know seven to ten p.m open
and close the store for a decade it's
Saturday included I would get Sundays
during the football season not a lot of
Sundays during not the football season
and you know and I never made a hundred
thousand dollars from 22 to 34 and you
know like that's hard and like you know
like and I um and so it's just like so
big big that I know it's true like I
know it's true that if you do the right
things and if you have the talent you're
gonna end up there and so I think I'm
just a very cliche not too crazy out of
the ordinary immigrant entrepreneur
story that valued family over themselves
first but I think what's unique about me
and that's only because the internet was
around you know had I been in the 50s
and 40s and 60s I just kind of want to I
probably would have 35 wine stores right
now right and I'd probably be maybe 50
50 partners with my dad probably not but
I would inherit it right but with the
internet I was able to speed up my
course plus I had 11 year younger
brother who I wanted to be in business
with that forced my hand a lot and uh
and then I think I'm a guy who like
really likes to see other people win
things are getting clearer for me of
like how I'm wired like Nick you know
this Sean you even know this by the way
our relationships have formed and a lot
of people here know this like I really
want people to [__] win I really want
it like why because I'm so [__] great
none of the nobody's taken for me I see
the [__] one of the great iconic
Legends of all time is here Snoop all of
snoop's winnings right all of your
winnings Nick all of Sean's winnings I'm
just gonna keep all of Sammy and Jake
and Vicky J like everyone's winnings
don't come from me I'm gonna get mine so
like you know if you're great you should
only be cheering for people there's no
time for Envy there's no time for
jealousy there's no there's no time for
gossiping at dinner tearing down
somebody that's winning I'm cheering for
Maverick Carter I'm cheering for like
everybody I'm cheering for [__] in my
own industry other Ad Agency if they're
good enough they're good enough Hawk
media good win like I'm cheering for
people because nobody's taking a penny
or a smile out of my pocket and so
that's who the [__] I am
no
no no no sure didn't I wouldn't have if
I wasn't that person I would have never
built something for my dad parents and
siblings aren't off you know aren't
hands off from this stuff they're not
exempt if you envy you envy your brother
and sister most if you envy you you envy
your sibling your your partner your
spouse your parents most this is how I
was born from the womb from the dirt of
Belarus this is who the [__] I was and
then
I was I was formed and and molded by my
mother who's the same person so I had
the luxury of the double down for a lot
of people here they're gonna understand
the double down a lot of us have the DNA
of one of our parents and then that
parent is the most impactful parent to
us others we have the DNA of the other
parent and they're not the one that kind
of did the hardcore parenting so I had
the DNA of my mom and then I had her
parented so I just became like the 2.0
version of her
amazing
the reason I asked if it came with age
is that I spent my early career in music
right coming up in the music game and
and in particular around hip-hop artists
right and there was a there was a When
We Were Young there was a level of
competition yes it was like it was very
very selfish
success Nick
nobody's more competitive than me on
this call I've already said that we
friends has to be the number one nft
project of all time
right to your point this is where people
struggle and I love that you said that I
used to cry until I was 17 anytime I
lost into anything my brother once beat
me in NHL 94 and I punched a hole in his
bedroom wall
like I'm plenty competitive like like
I'm like I'm I'm like in a bat I'm
actually I just did a podcast where I
said it's my darkest part I'm dark when
it comes to competitiveness but I don't
think people understand that you can you
can carry two opposite feelings at the
same time and they can co-exist this is
where everyone gets [__] up I'm
competitive and cheering for everyone
I'm the most hungry and ambitious and
I'm patient as [__] the [__]
superpower comes from the balance of the
opposite feelings
I get it no it makes so much because so
what I one thing I have noticed though
is as we've all gotten older at least
you know a lot of the the icons that
I've worked with whatever there's this
sort of Celebration now and there's this
sense of like there's this real sense of
love and and I I don't I just watching
it unfold right now has just been has
been really inspiring I think it's I
think it's I think it's I think it's
cliche that once you scratch or itch
then you are good at what I'm trying to
get the kids on here to understand is
when you're 20
and you want to be a supermodel an
athlete or the best entrepreneur you
want to be the next generation of the
people on this call like
you know it's then
if they if you're smart enough to be
gracious and happy for others and be the
bigger person
the depths of those relationships will
be greater Nick think about all the
icons of music that are now giving each
other roses but they were [__]
competing with each other because they
thought the world was scarce think about
think about how more beautiful their
relationships would be today and think
about all the I think this one's gonna
hit for you think about all the missed
Knights
all those concerts all those jingle
balls all those [__] BET Awards all
those nights where people could have
chopped up shared bread [__] been
family instead of [__] hating on each
other they missed those 700 nights yeah
no I think about it all the time I
really think about it and I think about
you know something that I if you can if
you can instill that and people
exactly you know
agree with you man and it's it's warm to
hear so I want to ask you another
question you are known as a collector I
see you collect you've inspired me to
collect I think it's probably how you
got to know Sean some of the other yeah
icons you know at heart like what what
was the first thing you collected like
how did you get into it because I think
that story is amazing for this for our
audience
baseball cards 1984 Subs nine Don
Mattingly was Yankee's first baseman he
was my hero and I just and then I like
you know I was we were like you know you
could tell the story and nobody believes
you but like we were poor like we didn't
get [__] like I didn't even know [__]
existed you know I guess a little bit
like you know like it was just this kid
Eric Conrad by the way Eric Conrad if
anybody can find Eric Conrad I think his
mom lived in Florida's dad lived in
Jersey in Edison New Jersey and Dogwood
Meadows and he would visit for the
summer and so like I've lost touch with
him like since 1987 but if you're out
there Eric Conrad with a dad and mom
that were divorced and dad was in Edison
New Jersey I'd love to chop it up like I
literally haven't talked to him since
1987 but from 84 to 87 we used to go
into his basement
and we would make card houses out of
decks of cards like literally for like
three hours and then we go play Wiffle
ball and basketball and it was the first
time I built card houses you know what
you know what I'm talking about right
like you take deck of cards and try to
build a fort or like a castle and then
one day we like ran out of cards and he
went he was like stay right here and he
ran upstairs and he came down and he had
baseball cards to add to our playing
cards
and I was like what the [__] is this
and I was like and I was already crazy
about the Jets and the Yankees and that
was it it was it was sports cards and
what's really neat because I've never
told that story it was because I was
building
Deck card houses out of playing cards
and Edward Conrad went upstairs and
brought down baseball cards that made me
realize they existed and within 13
seconds I'm like I need a Don Mattingly
baseball card and then I wouldn't and
then I'd take my bike or walk to
krausers which was like a 7-Eleven in
Jersey and then and then my I noticed
that at the counter there was baseball
cards and that's why I had to do
lemonade stands because I needed the
money to buy baseball cards because
that's the beauty of how I grew up like
my mom was not buying that [__] for us
money was for food and clothes and
shelter and so I learned how to get mine
early
thing resonates I'm from the same era
right so to this day that still hits
special hits home
um the uh the the Eric Conrad there was
an Eric Conrad in the it was a club
promoter in the um 90s in New York
um I don't think it's the same Eric
Conrad but I I've had my own Eric Conrad
in my life so there's a chance that was
Sarah Conrad's wait a minute did Eric
Conrad's were they divorce disappearance
when you buy the baseball cards was the
motivation at that point did it did it
turn into like a financial thing was it
about making money or was it about the
kind of the spirit of the collecting or
was it did you just love baseball I love
baseball I love Don Mattingly and then
and then two years later
there was the baseball card Club in
sixth grade remember there's
pre-internet kids so there was no
information out there for us kids and
I went to the baseball card Club in
sixth grade and then I saw a price guide
for the first time think about young
Gary seeing a price guide for the first
time
it'd be like [__] god seeing the
Bible like I was like I'm like this
shit's worth money it was [__] over
like
yeah
well that was the big one that came once
a year but before Beckett before Becca
there was this like black there was like
a non-colored printed uh baseball card
guide that would have like one primary
color on the cover but everything was
black and white and that was the first
one I think some people will tweet it
out because it was pretty prominent I'm
just blanking
um because I've never really Googled
back to try to get the name and then
like a year later Becca came out and by
1988 Ken Griffey Jr rookie card you know
it was over it took it took over the
culture
same
dad at the time was like die hard you
know Sports fanatic so it you know
started to wash onto me and dude I just
started getting into the baseball cards
and that was that moment that you speak
about like when I had that like Almanac
of the sports card prices it was like a
price guide
crazy to me because I would buy a pack
of cards for a dollar and then I
remember I would go through the book and
I would look up the value of each one
and some of them would be like 75 cents
or like 60 cents or like 15 cents or 10
cents but I was like Wow every pack is
always worth more than a dollar right
that's right
three dollars and
then a new pack of cards a car so sick
and this was so early on dude and what
you also learned because I'm gonna have
to run here soon for the dinner but I
want everybody to hear this me too I
want everyone to hear this very slow
because this will help with nfts this
will help with streetwear this will help
with everything
you saw and I saw wait a minute I bought
a pack for 35 cents because remember
this is OG land right
and
oh my God it all adds up to like 59
cents what you didn't know and I didn't
know then was nobody really wanted the
10 cent cards so there was no demand
against that perceived value number two
what you also knew was Mike Greenwell
was hot his rookie year and it went up
to two bucks but the next year he
slumped and the year after that he
wasn't that good and grimo was a little
bit better than that but I'm just play
with me here his rookie year it was
worth two bucks but 12 months later wait
a minute I thought cards were supposed
to go up why is this 80 cents now oh
wait a minute that's demand people don't
think he's going to be as good as Wade
Boggs or Ted Williams and so the things
we learned
in that era
of course we were going to be
unstoppable later of course you were
destined to understand supply and demand
and collectibility of course I was going
to be able to explode my dad's wine
business because people collected wine
by the time I was 18 I was a [__]
master I was spending 365 days a year 24
hours a day seven days a week focused
only on understanding why cards went up
and why they didn't why Ken Griffey did
why they didn't why Frank Thomas did
then they didn't wait a minute why are
Michael Jordan cards going up wait a
minute he's more popular than the game
he's in that Spike Lee commercial he's
on the Wheaties box oh that's why people
just like him that's called demand like
you start learning
what's crazy is to think that to you
both of you guys your careers have
essentially been inspired and are very
linked to this early collecting and
trading baseball card thing is
incredible because what your careers
will become I think a piece of content
we have to shoot 100 would be Gary
picking vintage clothes with Sean 100
I'm in bro listen the Vintage clothes
thing you guys you guys don't even know
I wish AJ was on here right now in 1998
when we were all about that eBay life we
were buying [__] like Iron Maiden
t-shirts for 25 cents and selling them
for 40 bucks like I like this is where
people always I always laugh when people
think I just pop onto something I made a
mocktails video the other day
um and somebody wrote a comment of like
well this Trends over now garyvee's here
I'm like my man I've been here for six
years just because I'm not talking about
it doesn't mean I'm not paying attention
I bought Ethan 15. like like uh like for
me like the Vintage clothes thing like
I've been going to you know thrift
stores and garage sales buying you know
t-shirts for 20 years I don't by the way
I don't rock them that's not my fashion
style I'm not that cool I'm not as cool
as everybody on this call I've you know
but but I'm aware of what the currency
is like I understood what it meant
before there was eBay in 1994 I was
buying Happy Days board games and Ronald
McDonald plush toss I didn't even know
that they were worth anything there was
no eBay I just knew Nostalgia and pop
culture and memories were the [__]
game V friends is not a random thought
because I saw an opportunity V friends
is a culmination of 40 Years of thinking
I love uh I love that line of
just because
being bad it doesn't
mean I really I think I can really
especially for me right now I apologize
for interrupting I just want to get as
much out for everybody you know
especially for me right now because the
second I say [__] people are speculating
I've got to be more quiet than ever now
oh the no the the Vintage collection's
long gone I flipped that [__] I find a
Bruce Spring yeah like like that was how
AJ made money back then right
like like you know like because I wasn't
rocking it and because like for me it
was like you know through the years then
I lived in Manhattan my parents don't
like they do like to hoard stuff which
means they don't want me to hoard stuff
at their house so like there's all these
different dynamics that led to like a
lot of stuff being sold there was a
flood I don't even want to talk about it
lost like 10th I me and EJ nailed the
video game thing crazy we were by Mike
Tyson punch outs for 25 cents at garage
sales in 2002 like it was our [__]
job
you know so anyway I gotta run I
apologize I love everybody I hope you
have a great sesh
thoughts in the future digital fashion
that's it what are you thinking about
you got any thoughts on that the world
is about and if something exists in the
in analog it's gonna exist in digital so
if fashion exists digital fashion is
gonna exist except the problem is 99 of
things are not going to work you know
like 99 uh of projects is not gonna
come through but the macro yes
okay got it man listen I
love you brother
by the way little little uh deal double
g style we can we'll talk about it okay
love it love everybody see ya
peace
[Music]